mood disorders are so severe that by the
time you go to a doctor you're desperate
you're like i've already tried things
i've already been exercising i've
already tried eating less i need help
right now otherwise i wouldn't be here
and the medical community isn't actually
educated in nutrition and the little
education they do get is straight from
the food guidelines which clearly aren't
working if i had to tell people i would
say the part of the problems with
medications is there are no long-term
studies past six to eight weeks which is
unbelievable for me psych meds nothing
past six to eight weeks so even if you
do go on one of those medications if
you're still depressed in a year they're
not going to start working in my opinion
they didn't work for me they worked
initially but i found out the hard way
when i tried to get off of them but i
think trying to reduce inflammatory
components in your diet simple things
could be cutting grains dairy switching
over to water instead of drinking juice
trying to eliminate soy trying to
prioritize meat whole foods greens and i
think if i had done something like that
as a kid i probably would have been able
to avoid the hip and ankle replacement